[Musique]
a été marquante pour le cinéma québécois
il met en vedette un monsieur à côté
bouleversant de le rôle d'un père de
famille qui ne sait pas trop comment
composer notamment avec le mot sexualité
de son fils joué par Mac André Grondin
la comédienne Daniel prou Campel rose de
l'épouse emère de famille je lui ai
parlé tout à l'heure
il m'a dit qu'elle avait invité chez eux
Daniel prou merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation une journée très difficile
une grande épreuve pour vous tous les
amis les collègues de Michel Côté mais
quel souvenir gardez-vous d'avoir été sa
femme dans cuisine dans un film qui est
devenu culte
une super belle aventure et c'était
surtout mais c'était moi c'était comme
un petit retour au cinéma ce que j'ai
quand même un petit bout que j'avais pas
tourné c'est très nerveuse en même temps
honoré parce que le scénario était
tellement extraordinaire et j'étais
aussi intimidée de travailler avec
Michel parce que je connaissais comme
grand facteur mais j'avais jamais
travaillé avec lui et c'est comme tout
le monde le dit tout le monde le dit
toute la journée c'est c'était un
rassembleur c'était quelqu'un qui
faisait que
vraiment une atmosphère très familiale
sur un plateau et comme on devait on
était une famille c'est serré du début
des années 60 on avait tous les deux des
souvenirs lui de sa famille de garçon
moi de ma grosse famille on s'est
partagé beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
on avait on voulait vraiment que notre
intimité soit crédible que c'est ses
parents là de ces cinq gars que ce soit
vrai comme on l'a connu dans nos propres
familles et en tout cas on était très
très fier de ce qu'on faisait à travers
ce film vous avez traduit une époque et
une époque importante dont il faut se
souvenir avez-vous sentiment à ce
moment-là de participer un film culte
notamment à une époque où on cherche à
lutter contre l'homophobie où les
familles sont devenu es en 2023 sur
l'entrée du fonctionnel mais que
ce film là
il y avait une portée sociale très
importante
dès la lecture du scénario Jean-Marc
nous avait envoyé scénario avec même le
CD qui a de toutes les musiques qui
accompagnaient chaque scène on pouvait
le lire le scénario avoir l'atmosphère
du film c'est rare que j'ai lu un
scénario que j'ai vu le film puis c'est
ça que j'avais vu et
et donc c'est on savait qu'on faisait un
grand film ça on le savait qu'il aurait
le succès qui a eu ça on le souhaitait
on se disait bien que beaucoup de gens
mais sommeil que le succès soit aussi
une année avec la critique avec le
public que le public a été au
rendez-vous aussi parce que c'est pas à
cette époque là c'était pas évident que
tout le monde se rendait au cinéma pour
voir un film québécois oui les films de
Denis Arca mais c'était pas c'est pas
tous les films québécois qui qui
faisait l'unanimité et puis on
s'attendait à ce que les gens aiment ça
m'ont s'attendait certainement pas à ce
que ce soit ce méga succès là c'est
connu c'est un homme de famille très
près de sa femme ses enfants petits
enfants c'était devenu un peu cette
priorité mais c'est valeurs là ça devait
être présent dans ce film là aujourd'hui
complètement complètement c'est sûr puis
on a eu au fil du tournage trois séries
d'enfants selon les époques alors on a
eu comme 15 et un garçon
puis à chaque à chaque petit groupe
Michel d'été on essayait vraiment de
faire une famille de faire de rendre ça
crédible et surtout comme c'était à
l'époque
les liens les rapports des gens d'un peu
de mots aussi il y avait pas c'est pas
du monde qui
débattait c'est pas des c'est pas des
gens de parole alors les mots il y en
avait pas énormément
mais donc c'est il y avait beaucoup une
grande chimie qui n'avait pas assez
excité
il y a un beau souvenir qui vous vient à
l'esprit que vous aimeriez partager avec
nous
mais en fait c'est la dernière fois que
je l'ai vu dans un gala on s'est croisé
donc c'est parlé puis on se regardait
des yeux puis on se disait comment on
était content d'être grand-parents
il y avait le goût de donner beaucoup
beaucoup de temps à ça puisque il était
tranquillement il y avait le bout de
vraiment diminuer puis
en même temps
à l'époque donc c'était vraiment prendre
la vie et comme il est un amoureux de la
vie de prendre la vie un volcan avec ses
enfants ses petits-enfants il y avait
des projets fait que c'était c'est la
dernière fois qu'on a eu vraiment une
conversation
un homme généreux tourné vers les autres
et se disait doué pour le bonheur
oh oui je pense que oui je pense que oui
il était il aimait la vie
fondamentalement il aimait les gens
j'étais curieux il était attentif il
était très observateur il était puis en
même temps il y avait un goût incroyable
sans humour
c'est un encyclopédie de blague et de il
y avait tout le temps un beau mot pour
pour tout le monde
mais en même temps très très rigoureux
c'est extrêmement c'est vraiment un
grand grand camarade de travail
un joyeux luron merci Daniel Praud
et de la console dans tous ces hommages
qui lui sont rendus aujourd'hui je pense
tellement Véronique à ses enfants et
petits-enfants
toutes mes pensées avec eux merci
au revoir
oui nos pensées sont avec eux Michel
vous me disiez que dans le fond monsieur
le côté c'était l'incarnation de l'homme
québécois
jusqu'à récemment regardez simplement
Brou c'est vraiment un panorama des
hommes québécois les hommes des tavernes
il l'extension s'est Cruising Bar c'est
4 hommes qui veulent jouer deux fois
dans la quarantaine dans la soixantaine
qui savent pas séduire donc c'est quatre
portraits d'hommes québécois le héros ça
c'est le commandant pichet le père
démuni qu'on a dans Crazy il y a toute
cette multitude d'images de l'homme
québécois tous les vantails se trouvent
dans le travail de Michel Côté bien sûr
De père en flic il était l'homme d'une
génération il incarnait complètement
j'aurais expliqué quelqu'un qui vient
s'installer au Québec c'est quoi les
valeurs du Québec mais on aurait déjà la
droiture qu'il représente parce qu'on ne
sort dans les film et puis la dérision
l'autodérision il y a au Québec un sens
de l'humour qui est là qui est présent
tout le temps des choses qu'on retourne
de mille façons mais il y a ça dans ces
personnages au sens de la composition on
évoquait tout à l'heure les compositions
mais il y avait aussi les bye bye
puisque il est allé aussi de ce côté-là
et puis des scènes qui sont inoubliables
dans Crazy le moment où il chante hier
encore avec un ustensile dans les mers
en guise de micro en se prenant pour
Aznavour puis on s'arrêtant à chacun de
ces enfants avec attention ça c'était le
personnage et c'était l'homme celui qui
avait comme ça un petit moment pour
chacun un côté vraiment très paternel ça
le représente bien jusqu'au moment
ultime où ils sont entendus avec son
film Zach et son fils Zack qui celui que
lequel c'est le plus difficile il faut
une grande finale ensemble ne serait-ce
que ça acteur de cinéma grand talent de
composition mais grand talent
d'intériorité
ça se mesure parfois au succès quelqu'un
qui a fait Brou qui a fait la petite vie
qui a fait omerta qui a fait le dernier
tunnel qui a fait de père en flics qui a
fait crazy et on peut continuer c'est
autant de marqueurs pour une société ça
c'est considérable certains acteurs ont
deux ou trois succès et puis après autre
chose lui sur 40 ans et moi je dirais à
partir d'eau claire de la lune au cinéma
parce qu'au début des années 80 un film
de Forcier dans lequel il y a un duo
avec guili Cuillier c'est un albinos
complètement décalé c'est une merveille
de le voir ça c'est début au cinéma déjà
là on est au début des années 80 on sait
qu'on est devant un grand acteur de
cinéma qui crée quelque chose
d'attachant
extraordinaire ce que vous dites et
aussi à la télé
le personnage qui accompagner nos 40
dernières années autant au théâtre au
cinéma à la télévision je pense au bye
bye 84 85 où il était en cours vedette
avec Marc Messier Dominique Michel et
Pauline Martin il y a il y avait une
multitude
il y avait une multitude de personnages
de latins le maire de drapeau que je me
rappelle par exemple une une prémisse à
Jean-Loup il faisait Boy George qui
chantait une ode à l'armée canadienne en
Boy George alors il fallait le faire
quand même en 84 puis il était capable
de tout ça c'est beaucoup d'audace
sachant nous faire aimer toutes ces
personnes tout à l'heure ce qui
l'évoquait avec lui Philippe oui mais
c'était dans son entrevue c'était le
dernier tunnel il joue un criminel mais
pour lui c'était important qu'on est de
l'affection qu'on comprenne cette
personne là c'est beaucoup ça
fallait le faire c'était audacieux parce
qu'il pouvait
mais il avait pas peur du ridicule dans
le sens de l'humour puisque on a évoqué
le travail des moules Gaudreault son
personnage est complètement insensé et
puis il est en même temps attachant
alors vous êtes intéressés
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI